[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on this episode of travel dares I'm
taking Nico - luck want be suave where
we're gonna cause a 200-foot suspension
bridge and I'm taking Caroline to
seminary Macias de lolicon where we're
gonna learn how soap is made come join
us on our adventures on this episode of
travel dares
[Music]
[Applause]
this is travel dares the show where we
do daring activities all over Europe
empowered by my Mariette Vaughn boy
boundless cards in this episode Nico and
I are in the South of France Nico how
you doing I am so excited I'm really
excited to be here I've always wanted to
come to the South of France and I can't
wait to get started yes so here is your
first clue and it over okay put your
best foot forward I have no idea what
that could mean to find out definitely
gonna be something like octaves but
either like maybe climbing running a via
ferrata is a climbing route using steel
cables that hikers secure themselves to
they are super popular among European
hikers and this one happens to have a
super scary bridge right in the middle
because I'm so excited I want to rip
this blindfold off almost there okay
take your blindfold because we are
walking across
[Music]
okay we're hiking up now we have about a
15-minute hike until we actually get to
the bridge I was half right about my
clue because we are hiking it up we are
we're doing something active I always
wanted to be a little more athletic John
I think so much muscle oh we're getting
really Steve here I'm there's no more
trails so we're just going on rocks now
all right so we're about to go on the
bridge finally made it
it's taken this was not 15 minutes let
me tell you that oh boy oh my god I
[Music]
don't know oh my god oh god you got this
girl right my arms are shaking go faster
Nick are you okay I'm good okay I'm
nervous second I'm on the bridge
Oh God okay okay hi sorry it's okay okay
oh my god yeah okay we're on the bridge
on the right side
are you doing me go good oh my god the
view I know
terrified but I've never felt more
confident in my life the air up here
isn't it does make me a little bit
nervous when the wind blows you're okay
Nico you got this let's sing a song I
feel like for something that scared me
so much just to get to I'm smiling a
whole lot this is like
once-in-a-lifetime I'm never gonna have
this view again I'm never gonna beat
this on top of the world again try
little Dix
[Music]
no one can ever say anything to me ever
again I am the bravest woman alive and I
don't care what you say we made it now
that we did it Caroline I feel really
good I do feel good we just did that
did that or we did that oh god that was
intense
oh the rocks are comforting to Caroline
[Music]
freaking proud of her yeah so proud that
was the wildest thing I've ever done
all right Nico now let's get off this
mountain I cannot believe we survived
that I know Nico that was probably one
of the hardest stairs we've done but you
absolutely killed it I'm so proud of you
thank you I hope I can say the same
about you when it comes to my there okay
well let's see what your clue is lather
up okay what a spa day most likely let's
hold okay
oh wait wait a minute I feel like we're
making soap but you look that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna make soap
something in the beauty world
I don't know and we're also gonna
integrate lavender in this somehow
that's what I think oh good stand right
there and stick your hand out sticks my
hand what hot that is
[Music]
Bonjour general nice to meet you thank
you for having us what are we doing
today we are making a level new subject
today is in this machine where there is
initial mix between oil and soda so
there is a sodium you not see because
all the sub are made with these cervix
fats and soda and here there is the
little places observe we are going to
put in this machine we make some pretty
beautiful surface and after when we have
this paper of so we are going to put it
in this mixer and after we are going to
prepare 8 the perfume and the color to
put in this machine Caroline I'm gonna
press the green button again and you
start pouring you got it this feels like
our soap is finally coming to life
and this machine can transform the
flakes absorb in tagliatelle of soap
makes bathtubs of the same machine to
make pasta next you are going to take
this talia tell observe to compact the
soap to give the final shape to
something ready get ready
let's see her so I know that I'm strong
your defenses are you can step to timers
one here one here me okay I'm gonna do
that boom boom that one's good I wanted
that what is really good enough to tell
you push it's gonna be loud I'm scared
it's like screeching take the excess off
it was weird
it's so weird oh my god Nico these are
gonna make such great gifts and we get
to tell everybody we helped make them
we've been to northern France and now
we're in the South of France and they're
both so different like they both have
their own unique charm to it yeah I
agree I definitely loved experiencing
the culture around here and the
croissants Nico are you ready for your
rating yes so I have to say this is
probably one of the hardest years we've
ever done on this show we had to climb
up that challenging mountain and then we
scaled down to get to the super scary
bridge and I'm so impressed of how well
you handled yourself so I'm giving you
five out of five yeah ten if I come five
on my first year at bear I'm so psyched
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you Caroline yes I was expecting you to
love soap making just because you're a
huge fan of everything Beauty you were
working that soap slicing machine like a
champ no fear that your fingers could be
chopped off at any moment and so for
that I will give you one
two or five of the lavender star you did
a really really good job still do so
good thank you so much Nico this was so
much fun I can't wait to go all over
Europe with you Cheers
[Music]